after two weeks to flatten the curve
turned into a year and a half to flatten
everything americans are taking it out
on the 1997 toyota corolla doing 29
in a 45 zone just ahead of them for mile
after mile 2021 is on pace to be a
record
setting year for deadly road rage with
increases in
everything uh from flipping the bird to
soccer moms to
shooting them for cutting you off here
now
is heather mcdonald author of the war on
cops and senior fellow
at the manhattan institute heather the
conventional wisdom
is that this is covid related stress do
you buy that
i don't buy it at all mark this is a
product of the delegitimation of law
enforcement
welcome to the total breakdown of law
and order
cops are not enforcing traffic laws uh
the department of transportation has
long documented that when
cops back off of traffic enforcement now
they're being told it's racist
to enforce traffic laws violent crime
goes up the
crime that we've been seeing just
terrorizing inner city the law-abiding
residents of inner city
is bleeding outwards into the roadways
people feel they can get away with
anything and you look at this
condition of city streets where anarchy
reigns nobody's enforcing the law
that sends a message generally that
nobody is in control
and people act out on their worst
impulses
that that sounds as if you put this in
the same category
uh as all those uh uh cities that have
said we're not we're not going to
prosecute
uh property theft under 900 bucks or
whatever
so you see people openly looting
walgreens in front of the manager
and the clerks in other words that when
you when you decriminalize
petty crime you shouldn't be surprised
that leads to other crimes
that's absolutely right last september a
principal in north minneapolis gave a
heart-rending video
saying we are a city completely and
literally out of control the cops were
not enforcing anything she complained
about the speeding
in her people running red lights and
they're not enforcing any of those
street level crimes again this sends a
message
that we don't expect lawful behavior and
a certain number of people are going to
say okay i'm just going to give in to my
impulses
we have got to stop demonizing the cops
stop demonizing law enforcement
it is not racist police officers are the
one government agency that cares
relentlessly about black lives that's
why they're in inner cities is to save
black lives but this phony narrative
that is being prosecuted by biden
his justice department that the entire
system is racist
is giving people license and you're
absolutely right the flash mobs we've
been seeing in chicago
in san francisco the looting the the
people
stamping on cars it's falling apart
very quickly mark and it's gonna it's
gonna take a massive change of ideology
to turn it around
i was astonished i flew back into the
country and landed at a big city airport
and i couldn't get any of my
minions to come to that big city and
collect me
uh because they just didn't they didn't
want to go to lawless american
cities i thought that was a little bit
crazy but i've talked to all kinds of
people and they too are giving the bums
rush to american cities
this is why the pandemic explanation for
the crime increase that the media
loves because they do not want to
acknowledge that policing matters
is so phony everybody had these insane
excessive hysterical lockdowns
throughout the western world
the only place where violent crime
increased was in the united states
only after the george floyd riots you
can go to
you can go to you know ireland and and
france and not have to worry about
drive-by shootings it is only here and
it's not due to the pandemic
because the press now says well now that
we've lifted the lockdowns now we're
going to have crime we had crime before
because of the lockdowns and now their
explanations because we're lifting the
lockdowns
they don't want to talk about policing
yeah that's
that's a true france and a lot of other
places had curfews
and they didn't have uh crimes like this
uh
that's uh that's an excellent point
heather thank you so much
for joining us tonight